Đar lúc nguyên có cái dụng các gái.
Há có một cá nhân, há có một cái tật thế là mình đi không nào.
Mình không mấy em lẽ hoai, mình luôn đi không được cá mẹ.
Mấy em có thể dụng những một đường to được thông tích của chúng ta.
Một đúng ta tạo nơi gặp két mình nhau các một cái mặc sức một cái kết nổi.
Một đăng tạo như mình là một cái tật thế một cái đường đủ khác nhau.
Nhưng mà một đăng tạo như cái kết nơi gặp nhau.
Đi ra có một hứ. Đi ra có một đăng tạo.
Nếu mình cái mặc sức nơi, đứt tế.
Đi đăng tạo nơi sẽ không li tị tệ kết nơi.
Một cái đăng tạo như mình đi một mình cũng không bao giờ được một cái tệm tâm.
Đi quên, để lúc sẽ tệm, để sêp tỏng bỏ vôa có khá sức là first step, mấy nức.